hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in to see how your
weeks going is it going well is it going
in a direction that you wanted to be
going in you're going somewhere is it's
the way you want to be going you know
people when we get on these tracks in
life and we feel the direction of our
lives not going in the direction we
wanted to go in
you know it's high time that somebody
lets you know that you have the power to
stop that trade to turn it around in the
tracks even though this metaphor makes
no sense can't turn a [ __ ] train
around how do you turn a train around
you got to go to a train yard right you
got to get a bunch of people that are
missing digits right to disconnect some
[ __ ] right you know I think I think all
the cars stay where they are and then
they disconnect the locomotive and that
thing just bangs a little Yui there
because if you try to bang them while
they're all in a truck I gotta be honest
with you I don't know how you do it but
I'm here to fix your life what is it
about I wonder you know I'm gonna get
out of this whole [ __ ] comedy
business and I'm just gonna [ __ ] you
know I gotta get into the Joel Olsteen
world I am so [ __ ] envious of that
guy that guy is a [ __ ] genius
he sells out a basketball arena every
single Sunday once a week he does an
arena gig everybody's talking about
Kevin Hart's doing a football set this
[ __ ] guy sells out an arena every
single Sunday that's a tough day to sell
an arena okay
people are hung over from Friday and
Saturday he sells out where the Houston
Rockets used to play he bought that
thing put down some electric blue carpet
and everybody comes to him he sells out
a basketball arena every single week the
same [ __ ] arena he doesn't have to go
on the road you know he's not going to
George W Bush Airport
herbert walker [ __ ] whatever
international airport right next to
Halliburton at now is called Larry's
[ __ ] widgets whatever the [ __ ] they
call it down there right this
[ __ ] just sits there and he lets
the crowd you know it's he's got his own
private Branson Missouri his own Las
Vegas they come from miles around and
their shiny pickup trucks their
girlfriends named Darla right all [ __ ]
made-up just an ozone layer perfume just
walk it into that [ __ ] place and he
goes up there right there's [ __ ] eyes
closed you know and just tells these
people what they want to hear that's the
business I want to get in he doesn't
have to pay to rent the [ __ ] thing
out and it's also a religion so he
probably doesn't pay any taxes he's got
his own TV show so you know he has
groupies I mean this guy I mean write
down the checklist everybody's talking
about Ford verse Ferrari and what how
Ford came up with this this amazing
sports car that beat Ferrari what about
Joel Olsteen versus every [ __ ]
entertainer in this country you know and
you know you got you Vegas acts that are
they're doing a residency but they don't
own the casino Joel Osteen went out and
he bought his own flamingo and he
headlines it fifty-two Sundays a year
he's got his own TV show he's got his
own radio show he's like that guy there
Ryan Seacrest except I don't think Ryan
Seacrest could sell out the Staples
Center every single weekend fifty-two
Sundays in a row doing his version of
[ __ ] Rock and New Year's Eve in the
top 40 there's only one guy in this
country that can do it that's Joel
Olsteen
and I think it's high time when Forbes
talks about the highest-grossing
entertainers out there that they stick
this guy
at the top of the [ __ ] list I didn't
think Elvis could [ __ ] play Houston
fifty-two Sundays in a row and his
height treat me like a fool I don't
think I'm oh you never know those same
[ __ ] people would come down there
they go see him on a Saturday and then
all those woman's would go down on
Sunday - Joel Osteen's - confess their
sins anyway I don't know
so anybody knows a [ __ ] rundown arena
is the is the [ __ ] the silver dome in
Michigan still available get together
with all things comedy we'll buy that
and I'll just move to [ __ ] Pontiac
Michigan right I'll get an old Pontiac
and I'll [ __ ] drive it in every
goddamn week and I will do my [ __ ] and
dick jokes wearing a suit a little red
tie my eyes closed and I'll just tell
you what you want to [ __ ] hear huh
let me just practice I gotta practice my
new Act I mean look at you you listening
to this podcast I mean right there you
know you're alive you know you're
special you know that Jesus cares about
you they didn't care about you why would
he give you ears to listen to what I'm
saying to you right now and I'm just a
vessel of his words and it's cold from
up high and it's just passing through me
and it's going right into you it's like
a virus except it doesn't kill you it
makes you live forever praise Jesus
everybody put the hands together put
your hands together every close your
eyes so cuz some reason if your eyes
closed you can't really see the [ __ ]
that's coming at you
speaking of [ __ ] coming at you oh
Jesus Bernie Sanders swept up by doo doo
doo dude he went into New Hampshire and
he [ __ ] won that goddamn primary
didn't he whatever the [ __ ] you call it
he won that little [ __ ] debate I
don't understand why everybody just
doesn't like that guy or the mainstream
media just won't get on the Bernie
Sanders train as they sit there [ __ ]
moaning and complaining about Trump and
I really think that they like the
Trump's out there because it gives him
some to whine about if Donald Trump
wasn't president
right and Hillary Clinton won what the
[ __ ] would CNN app to talk about
they already ball washed [ __ ] Obama
for eight years and then what do they do
ring out their [ __ ] sponges and then
continue with Hillary they needed him to
go and then look at me say bad guy they
needed that guy I'll tell you is having
a hard time is Fox News those guys they
having a tough time well you know
something that the left would just leave
Trump alone then they'd have nothing to
talk about them because they have their
ultimate guy right he's out there you
know he's got his trophy wife he's
grabbing [ __ ] he's shaking off
lawsuits right he's gluing that toupee
on this is what the [ __ ] they're all
about and then it gives to the left
loves it because they get to be like oh
my god is this the worst thing ever
as you sit there in your limited-edition
SUV with your [ __ ] heated leather
seats your wine and [ __ ]
I like Bernie Sanders man I like Bernie
Sanders first Donald Trump those are
gonna be the grit that will be one of
the greatest debates in the history of
politics okay you got a rogue rightie in
a rogue lefty the pay-per-view matchup
that everybody wants to see it's going
12 rounds this is not going to be Mike
Tyson versus the Spanx Jenks Michael
Spinks I'll never forget that our pizza
just arrived yes okay the old freckles
he's [ __ ] you know what I'm doing an
acting gig this week day uh you know I'm
not supposed to talk about it but you
know because you guys are VIP you know
what I mean you board before Group one
on Delta Airlines those [ __ ] silly
[ __ ] right [ __ ] [ __ ] you're not
Group one if other groups board before
you anyway I liked it I like that group
one you're in Jesus group one except I
go in first cuz I got an arena and I
make him all kinds of money you know
when I first started preaching about
Jesus Jesus just wore a loin
now he's got a Sean John tracksuit
because of me he still got that
loincloth underneath it praise Jesus
anyway I'm doing this we're doing a
reboot of new girl we're on the lead
it's called new guy right and I you know
I just moved to town I don't know
anybody so I go out for tapas that's the
pilot all right and I'll talk to you
guys you know I'll talk to you during my
lunch hour here my lunch break probably
half are probably gonna work through it
all right it's gonna be a long day but
in your world it's just gonna be a quick
edit right would it be great if you
could just edit the best parts to your
life together just splice let me cut out
the bad parts but you know it's not just
we want to do that if we don't
experience the pain then the pleasure
yeah it doesn't if he just feels normal
close your azan and thank Jesus for the
pain in your life praise Jesus I'll be
back in just a moment
it's ain't just like that I'm back it's
not my lunch break though I just went I
did my little no hair and makeup you
know I was thinking about Joel Olsteen
again you know what it's like it's like
he's a agoraphobic except with like
traveling you know or like performing
like he can't leave that place and you
know and now I'm starting to think you
know now that I had a couple minutes
here while they painted my head you know
what I mean so the shine wouldn't
[ __ ] blind you on your big
flat-screen TVs like what is that a
meaty or
huh is that a fallen step oh wait oh
wait it's just a pasty freckled [ __ ]
Jinja do you know it's actually problem
with my acting like they tell me I can't
move too quickly on screen because it'll
it'll like literally you know all the
people out there that are on edibles
like it just would trip them out if I
[ __ ] trip them out is that how the
old people talk about [ __ ] drugs
it's tripping me out man I'll [ __ ]
back-trace it anyways yeah it's like
he's
[ __ ] agoraphobic so now I'm actually
thinking that you know he stayed in
Houston too long so he's got a wonder
you know am I am I to regional now like
does my does my act travel like what if
I what if I went out okay
and I took the equity that I have in the
[ __ ] Houston Rockets place and then I
bought the I bought the Key Arena in
Seattle right with the Seattle
SuperSonics with downtown Freddie Brown
used to [ __ ] play right what if I
bought that thing okay and then like I
don't know every other weekend I go to
Seattle then I try to get those sad
soaking wet Lumberjacks with their Pearl
Jam flannels right and their [ __ ]
high-top Doc Martens to come in you know
he'd have to go a little Eddie Vetter
when he got up there you know saving a
Jesus actor hey buddy fair she does that
Reid you know you'd have to bring it
down
that's what grunge was I thought grunge
was just singing lower because I'm not
gonna lie to you I I have had Sirius
satellite in my car for the like the
last three four years and I just kind of
kept on the same [ __ ] I listened to
Howard Stern the NHL Channel and then I
had these are my safe thing I got Ozzy's
boneyard and then I had the 80s the 70s
and the 60s you know as far as like
whatever right so I just flipped through
those things and that was kind of it and
I listened to Red Sox or Bruins games or
whatever on the [ __ ] really high
channels so I started flipping through
all these other ones and I found this
channel called hair nation and it's like
all the [ __ ] hair metal and [ __ ]
you know cloned band at the band after
band you know they play a lot of the bad
[ __ ] too right
so I was listening to it yesterday right
and this band tora tora came on and this
[ __ ] guy you know he you know the
band's [ __ ] playing a little noodling
around with the guitars and again and he
does a little move right and then right
before they get to go into you
like [ __ ] like a goddamn [ __ ] cat
just screaming like a [ __ ] Alley Cat
and I was just like they must have just
been up there and sialic because they we
know they were of a certain age right
they were a little older than me and
they were like I'm so [ __ ] sick of
these [ __ ] alley cats you know we got
we got we have to rebel against this
[ __ ] so they went from wolf
it's a [ __ ] repo dodo right or who's
that kind and Lane Stanley we just sing
the whole [ __ ] line they went they
went completely the other way they let
their balls drop in Seattle which was it
was easy for them see LA was more
exciting and everybody ho there their
eyebrows up and it pulled their nuts up
into their body and that's why they sang
like that and up in Seattle you know
there's just no hope
Seahawks sucked ken griffey jr. was you
know on his way out right basketball
team he had Shawn Kemp [ __ ] knocking
up anything that moved out they can you
blame the guy it's [ __ ] raining all
the time all his buddies at down in LA
banging [ __ ] models and [ __ ] and he's
up there what does he got huh
bunch of hairy leg brog with [ __ ]
soaking wet pubes hang it down offer
their hoo-has
the guy was depressed so I think you
know everybody's head was hanging down
and you know it's the way you hold your
body so all these Seattle singers their
balls dropped and then that's well
that's how they started singing that way
that's a true story - I saw Kurt Loder
talking about a way back in the day it
was an amazing piece of footage on MTV
News but added a dil-don't dough dome
well [ __ ] did that come from anyway any
do you know I was actually talking to
somebody about yesterday there was a
commercial it was a toy a long time ago
called mr. microphone all right
and the whole thing was it was it looked
just like the microphone I had was the
microphone and a little orange top on it
and it was the 70s everything had an
orange windscreen on it it was mr.
microphone you somehow you plugged it
into your
radio and then when you talked like your
radio became like a boombox and these
people all freaking out like oh wow me
and I'm on the radio you know like they
would be like they'd be it like the
commercials like you're at like a party
like wow man this party's boring like
it's not boring it's the 70s nobody
knows cocaine's addictive yet right but
now they all act like they're [ __ ]
bored so this guy goes away I got this
and he pulls it out of his inside sport
coat pocket mr. microphone yeah what
said he plugs it into the radio the guys
that go wow man I'm on the radio so
they're showing all these stupid fun
activities that you do with this [ __ ]
microphone was like [ __ ] 12 13 bucks
to 1298 assumption so they show these
poor little kids singing around a
Christmas tree or something like that
hilarious cuz like they're now all in
their 50s you know and then the best one
was the one at the end this is what made
me look it up because this this guy with
like curly [ __ ] hair in the back of a
convertible and he's driving down the
street he's in a car full of people he
just yells at some woman walking down
the street he's like hey good-looking
we'll be back to pick you up later
right now in my mind I remembered a
woman walking down the street but I just
I found the clip and there's there's no
there's no you don't see who he's
yelling at but you know it's a woman
right but they didn't show a woman so
they could get out of it because I just
thought that that you know I missed that
America you know I mean when you could
sell a product well you can be the life
of the party you know have fun with mr.
microphone harassing women as they try
to walk down the street a man I like
your tits mr. microphone
fun fun fun for white males and King and
convertibles whatever I'll post that
I'll post that video but if you watch I
really do believe it's a woman because
the chick that's next to him hits him
like Oh sexual harassment stop it wasn't
harassment back then you know what it
was it was life and I'll tell you those
broads back then they were a lot tougher
than the ones
you know there's been an overcorrection
now these women today oh Jesus Christ I
mean you just you [ __ ] look at a god
like right now I'm looking at a [ __ ]
standing lamp you know and they probably
like oh yeah yeah bet you wish all women
was shaped like that huh you body shame
and white toxic piece of [ __ ] it's like
no that's not what I was thinking I was
thinking like what if I was Joel Olsteen
and I played a basketball arena every
weekend and I never had to leave my
hometown oh my god that guy's life I
want to go there and I want him to pray
for me for how much I covet what he has
[Music]
you're in [ __ ] Houston Texas all
right who's kidding - it's gonna be hot
as balls but you know I think and get
over that with your air-conditioned
arena right you got probably some
[ __ ] sick ass ranch you know all
kinds of [ __ ] land you know and you
just sit in there there's got to be
pressure during the week like God God
how am I gonna sell this Jesus week this
Sunday what I go what am I gonna look
forward you know every day right you do
your cardio you know what I mean you
[ __ ] hanging out you know maybe a
little bourbon who gives a [ __ ] right
you bless it no harm no foul right and
you open up your Bible you break there's
always some [ __ ] story that in there
that you can read and put your twist on
it you know I think it means this I
think is everybody thinks something
different right look at this poor
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that's going on now
like Jeremy Roenick makes a joke in a
podcast now he doesn't have a [ __ ]
job right and then you just look at
everybody talking about it and then
everybody like to some people it's not a
joke to other people it's a joke to some
people they see a gray area and then
other people they see nothing wrong with
it and then they write [ __ ] way worse
than anything that was even said that
caused the whole [ __ ] story to begin
all right you take the [ __ ] craziness
of that [ __ ] and you just apply that
to the Bible and next thing you know you
are selling out an arena I want two feet
did he start like small like how do you
become is there like a preacher open mic
weather just like all right this next
preacher coming to the stage he's a
really funny guy he's been talking about
Jay
is up and down the East Coast and it
cultures please welcome Joey
Ola Steen and then it comes up there
it's Joe Joey Olsteen but that's okay
because Jesus forgives Jesus doesn't
care if you called him hey Suz career
high heist he would just deed look the
other way and turn the cheek that's okay
I'm praying for you why don't you okay
that guy over there hit must have too
much of the devil in him must had a
couple of devil dogs when it came in
because the Devils in that satanic
desert and he keep it go over Joey
Holstein right he bombs for a while then
eventually he just [ __ ] he starts
getting into a groove right I didn't
forget the first time I was on stage and
I got somebody to say praise Jesus
without asking the crowd to say praise
Jesus and I was like praise Jesus that
guy just said praise Jesus because that
was praising Jesus and it was it was in
that moment I knew that I was on my
weight that I could talk about this guy
who may or may not have existed who may
or may not be hot and I could make some
money first thing I did was I bought an
old Cracker Barrel that went out of
business and well you know I started
filling that thing up I want to know the
story how did he get to a [ __ ] arena
and the man simply does not have to
leave his [ __ ] ranch every week you
know what everybody everybody goes to
Mecca I figured why wouldn't they come
to Joey Joey o lil anestine talking
about hey Suz Kira highest inside an old
[ __ ] arena you know it'd be great
what if I [ __ ] if reunion arena where
the Dallas Mavericks still used to play
right what if that place still existed
what if they didn't implode that and I
bought that okay and I went against the
grain he's down in Houston and he's
praising Jesus I would go there and I
would praise I would go to Dallas and I
would pray Satan you know but I would
steal his delivery right because I'm
evil eye just like Satan want you to do
anything that you
do you want to grab a [ __ ] you know
it's good enough for the president it's
good enough for you that's right build
the wall around anybody doesn't look
like us praise praise Satan right now I
would just [ __ ] do that then I'd make
my money and then I could get on TV
shows and Jane Pauley would be
interviewed no but don't you feel the
social responsibility for what is it
you're putting out there I know no I
don't if you look at all all the
commercials on TV they're telling you
they're telling you get that flat screen
they're telling you get that hot tub
they're telling you go out there and get
that wakeboard they telling you to go
out there and just have fun fun fun till
the daddy takes the t-bird away now that
was the Beach Boys they're one of the
most wholesome acts in all of pop music
praise Satan I could just go the
opposite way what I'm trying to say
people is that I'm gonna start doing the
road coming up in March okay and I've
taken a little bit of time off as I've
tried to put together my new hour here
and I gotta tell you I did not miss lax
I ain't gonna Lottie but uh just the
[ __ ] thought I going to that
godforsaken horse shape shoot they put
the [ __ ] in [ __ ] horseshoe horseshoe
horseshoe shaped horse shaped the [ __ ]
will praise Satan horse shaped why don't
you what you need to do is get a [ __ ]
and in naylor to the top of your door
make sure her mouth and her pumps are
faced upward so the [ __ ] doesn't
horniness does not pour out the ends
praise Satan and you two can live in a
cathouse because Satan wants you to live
in there all right I know somebody's
gonna send clips of this to some [ __ ]
Jesus Freak and then I'm gonna have some
goddamn [ __ ] bye you stalker coming
at me alright let's let's read a little
bit of advertising here price Satan and
praise Madison Avenue and let's see what
we got here oh by the way your Boston
Bruins that better but
pampas won six of the last seven well
Badou do petite bébé P we beat the
[ __ ] Canadians last night with thirty
five and eleven Canadians at 27 and 25
with just a C a [ __ ] mediocrity on
that team I went to [ __ ] daily faceoff
and I was trying to look at the number
one two lines you know and the
defenseman I'm just you know and I went
Seinfeld when I looked at I was like who
um alright where the hell is my
advertising here where is it oh where is
my advertising oh where could it be
oh there we go you know what that's from
those from The Courtship at Betty's
father
I've never been able to find that
episode but one time we were watching
the episode you know they had the Asian
woman on that thing was I don't know
what her deal was she was like some sort
of I know he was a widower and she came
over there made sandwiches or something
and she called him mr. Eddie's father
alright and at one point she was in the
kitchen and she was looking for a frying
pan now I know that I've told this story
before she's looking for a frying pan
and then out of nowhere as she was
looking for there's been no music they
haven't broken any fourth wall whatever
the [ __ ] this is she's looking for the
frying pan and all of a sudden this
person sings in the background like oh
where is the frying pan oh where could
it be
somebody please find that [ __ ]
episode and explain what I can't imagine
being writers from pitching them um Oh
max here we are everybody we're into the
advertising here Oh max praise Satan Oh
max living with chronic pain is the
worst it's more than a feeling of more
than a feeling of discomfort it can
affect your whole life many of my
listeners have some type of pain that
has prevented them from relaxing and
sleeping or stop them from exercising
Jesus Christ starts describing my life
before I tried Oh max perhaps it's been
ongoing for a few weeks now and as it
improved with any of the treatments
they've tried podcast host to provide
experience of recent pain
when I sit down to long life my feet
fall asleep so I've had to like from
years of flying on planes and sitting
down in cars bill Oh Billy backside all
I got back there was just [ __ ] skin
and bones so what I've had to do is I've
had to do a lower body regimen of squats
and thrust and all of this [ __ ] and now
my feet are better and you know what I'm
happy more happy for this has nothing to
do with Oh max I used Oh max on my
shoulder why the [ __ ] would I talk about
my feet enter Oh max health if you're
looking to get rid of nagging muscle and
joint pain immediately while providing
long lasting oh that's what I was going
to talk about because my left knee might
would hurt so I had to get one of those
[ __ ] ace bandage things that they
self to old people in the foot aisle at
the the [ __ ] drugstore and that
doesn't work you see how old people
hobble around but I used some Oh max and
I put it on me first of all I felt
wintery green fresh and I'll talk do you
know what it does it gets rid of the
goddamn irritation is what it does enter
Oh Max and I put it on my left shoulder
my right knee and my right shoulder
our ASIS left knee left shoulder left
hand side the devil sad is not as good
the Jesus side is doing fine if you're
looking to get rid of nagging muscle and
joint pain immediately while providing
long lasting net recovery then you need
to try the natural breakthrough pain
relief solution cryofreeze CBD CBD
roll-on developed by Oh max health I
love this [ __ ] this non-prescription
triple action pain relief roll-on is
specially formulated to block pain
receptors reduce inflammation improve
muscle and joint flexibility the best
part is this 100% natural CBD powered
remedy works its magic within 10 minutes
of application released less up to eight
hours much longer than the
over-the-counter products that's what I
do I go to the gym I workout I ice my
shoulder and then the end I put on a
little bit of CBD and I'm good to go
and I got to tell you some 48 year old
broads have been checking me out lately
i I skew a little older Oh max health is
offering my listeners my listeners 20%
off
a full bottle of cryofreeze CBD pain
relief roll-on plus free shipping it's
easy it's roll-on it's like deodorant
except you're putting it on your
shoulder instead of underneath it this
discount also applies towards any
product site-wide just go - Oh max calm
today and enter promo code Burpee URR
that is o M a exhale calm and enter code
BRR
to get 20% off cryofreeze site-wide
still not sold well still that soul I
can tell you pro athletes such as PGA
pro golfer kyle Stanley uses cryofreeze
CBD to recover from both on and off the
course oh wow he's rolling it on between
shots and and go look at the product
reviews they've got 95% five-star
reviews page after page of customers
saying they've tried everything in Oh
max cryofreeze is so good they are
buying it for their family and their
friends - that's right and look at
looking there look at that one
professional athlete is that's promoting
it a golfer alright that's not an
athlete he's a regular person just like
you and me and he hurts after 18 holes
of golf and if it works for him then god
damn it it'll work for you alright
lastly but not leastly stamps calm
everybody you know who's got time to
worry about things like postage
especially when rate seems to change
every year
yeah it's called inflation that's right
postage rates have gone up again but
here comes stamp stock here comes Dan
stock on the outside it's easy the pain
and big discounts the way it seat its
weight but here comes stamps to come to
ease the pain with big discounts off
post office retail rates they'll even
calculate postage for you so you don't
have to deal with it man you know about
stamps con they've been sponsoring the
show for over seven years now and if you
haven't tried it what the hell are you
waiting for
stamp stock rom you save five cents off
of every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off [ __ ] and that's great when you touch
the screen and all of a sudden all this
[ __ ] starts happening up to 40% off
shipping rates that kind of saving
really adds up especially for small
businesses plus businesses plus stamps
telecom is completely online which say
you time no more inconvenient trips to
the post office or having to deal with
morons in LA traffic what if you want to
abandon your family now you have one
less excuse to get out of the house but
if you're a good guy stamps.com brings
all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your computer whether
you're a small office sending invoices
an online seller shipping out products
or even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can handle it
all with ease stamps com not only saves
you time it saves you money too but
stamps.com you get discounted postage
rates that can get get can even that you
can't even get at the post office sorry
I just had a [ __ ] anxiety attacked
about how much content is still left or
copy is still left here and there's no
equipment to lease and no long-term
commitment stamps calm is a no-brainer
saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm right
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the type of on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in BER bu are our that stamps
commenter bar alright I got to go on set
when I come back I'm gonna tell you how
the XFL can becoming a success alright
he's back he's back and he's redder than
ever
alright this is what I would do if I was
running the XFL okay you're in the XFL
you know you're not the NFL you know
you're not the NFL you're not right
you're not the NFL alright that's what
that's who the [ __ ] you're trying to
beat eventually or hoping that someday
they will merge with you whatever the
hell it is you're trying to do so this
is what you got to do you got to
establish some level of excitement
alright now back in the day what that
meant was to get a bunch of beautiful
women scantily clad running around
giving away free [ __ ] that's how they
used to do it but now because of women
who aren't good looking good looking
dumb women now have a more difficult
time exploiting their bodies to get
themselves a nice 2-bedroom apartment
okay so that's out the window that ship
pray Satan
this is what I would do back in the day
when the NFL was the NFL and then he had
the AFL they would play their games
right and then in the end of the NFL
season they play the NFL championship
game and the AFL play the AFL
championship game and then what they
started to do was after those games they
played an NFL AFL championship game
which later was was called Super Bowl
one in two you see when I'm gone with
this and three I believe all right so
for a Super Bowl I think being Super
Bowl four I think that was the first one
called the Super Bowl won by your Kansas
City Chiefs they won Super Bowl four and
Super Bowl 54
all right so all you people in [ __ ] in
Kansas City Missouri each of goddamn
vegetables because you got to sit it out
until Super Bowl 104 I think that's how
it works all right I'm not good at math
anyway plowing ahead this is what I
would do I would have the champion of
the XFL play the champion of the CFL
right has a little nod to Super Bowl one
two and three then all you need is some
Joe Willie guy to say we're gonna beat
these mother okay now you know what you
got an American versus a Canadian thing
who's second tier League is better all
right that's what you do and every other
year you play by XFL you rules and every
other year you played by CFL rules our
best second string professional league
can beat your one and only second string
professional league the CFL because CFL
is always going to be second string even
though they're the only Football League
in Canada because they're always going
to be second to to Canada in Hockey
Night in Canada I don't care how many
old people they fire these these Canucks
are still gonna watch that [ __ ] so
that's what I would do
all right that's my little that's my
little business plan and by the way me
and Bert Kreischer are gonna go to that
XFL the LA Wildcats versus the Dallas
renegades the home opener I like to root
for up-and-coming Leakes you know what I
mean
that's why I like when they first
started showing those [ __ ] degenerate
gamblers on ESPN I watch
that [ __ ] right here comes the river the
river right what the [ __ ] world series
of poker I started watching the World
Series of Poker there is no [ __ ]
reason to call it the World Series maybe
no actually that isn't a I think that's
an official World Series because they
got degenerates from all around the
world you know alright I believe that's
the podcast I think I've done my
contrast she required half-hour I'm not
good at math what I do it's like 20
minutes I did like 8 minutes and 3
that's 31 hour I think we're good now
you're gonna listen to a little bit of
[ __ ] music here picked up by the one
and only Andrew stemless and then you're
gonna get a bonus half-hour episode of
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast followed after
the music all right you guys have a
wonderful weekend watch your XFL games
watch your hockey games do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do you know whatever
the hell you want to do but I got to get
back to new New Girl the reboot
what would you guys call it we need a
working title new ginger new guy shy guy
[Music]
and it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday February 13th 2012
yes it is folks it's Valentine's Day
that completely made-up horseshit
holiday that you don't have to
participate in that goes down tomorrow
did you make reservations everybody huh
you're gonna go out to the little fancy
steak house celebrate your your
relationship while you pay for a hundred
percent of it is that what you're gonna
do it's the big [ __ ] holiday it
starts tomorrow you know what I did last
night I took my I took her out to dinner
we decided that we're gonna celebrate it
last night and I gotta tell you it was
[ __ ] awesome III can't remember a
Valentine's Day that I enjoyed more than
this one it was great we went into this
dis [ __ ] awesome sushi restaurant
which is normally packed anyways just
for the [ __ ] of it forget about on
Valentine's Day but because it was two
days before Valentine's everybody wants
to come in on on Tuesday we go in there
last night there's nobody [ __ ] there
it's nobody there all right that's how
you celebrate holidays other than
Christmas okay cuz Christmas the
difference between Christmas and
Thanksgiving is you actually get those
days off so who gives a [ __ ] right the
thing about all these other [ __ ]
ones is you don't have to you just it's
a suggestion we think it should be the
14th really I think it should be the
12th when food cost what the [ __ ] it
should cost and I can actually get a
goddamn table alright and I can focus on
the girl I love rather than looking
around the room and being distracted at
all these other women and how they're
dressed up you know oh look at the way
she has her tits hanging out you know
oh look at all this stuff they got oh
did he get a [ __ ] goddamn bouquet of
[ __ ] flowers like they drape around a
horse and now he's putting it around his
[ __ ] woman does he understand that he
just made her look like a [ __ ] horse
I don't want to deal with all of it I
don't want to deal with it I don't so
when's the next big holiday that's
coming up people
it's [ __ ] st. Patty's Day alright one
of the most racist [ __ ] holidays
there ever was but you don't hear Jesse
Jackson bitching about that one but he
walked around with green plastic [ __ ]
hats getting drunk puking up their
[ __ ] corned beef sandwiches and
celebration of Irish heritage is there
any other [ __ ] holiday like that
where are the Native Americans they're
all pissed off at [ __ ] Braves fans
and Redskins fans sit there focus and
all on that as they sit on the streets
in New York playing that sad
white man took our music took our land
music I'm sorry
you ever hear those people when they get
out there with those [ __ ] centaur
flutes that they play it is the saddest
most depressing you know everything was
great until you came here evil white man
music I've ever heard in my life you
know I don't want the [ __ ] well where
the [ __ ] is their outrage about st.
Patrick's Day the green alligators and
everybody just sitting there I'm trying
to think if there is another holiday out
there you know okay
Black History Month for the whole
[ __ ] month the white people go around
and [ __ ] who have their pants hanging
off their ass and do a bunch of
stereotypical African American [ __ ] that
would be really [ __ ] offensive now we
don't white a [ __ ] on st. Patrick's Day
oh it's st. Patrick's Day let's
everybody dress in the colors of the
Irish flag and act like a bunch of drunk
[ __ ] idiots oh I'm on my soapbox this
morning um alright what are we gonna
talk about this week did you guys watch
the Grammys last night you know I
watched a little bit of that [ __ ] Bruce
Springsteen came out once again and sang
that song that sounded like all these
other songs like every other song and
I'm driving down that [ __ ] Highway
and I even though I'm a loser I'm still
gonna make it cuz I got my girl and five
eating slices and throwing rocks at
dirty [ __ ] seagulls you know I got it
Jesus Christ unbelievable that he made
people care that much about New Jersey
is right there just shows you the level
of the caliber of artists that he is
that he could really make people care
that much well so says Bruno Mars I
think that guy's the [ __ ]
um oh my god you like him what are you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you I can give it up for
somebody you know going out there and
his Elvis Gold Lemay's fifty thousand
Elvis fans can't be wrong
it was great I thought he put on a hell
of a [ __ ] show I actually watched it
and I was like you know what if he did
that for an hour I would pay to go see
him I thought he had a great show and
everybody was all sad about Whitney
Houston right wouldn't he Houston passed
away he's [ __ ] brutal man everybody
died in you know and I was really sad
that she died until that [ __ ] girl
came out from the [ __ ] and I'm not fat
anymore commercials and she sang that
song that made me want to kill myself I
like Whitney Houston god rest her soul
but I didn't ever needed to hear that
[ __ ] how many [ __ ] I got it you can
sing how about leaving Letty we [ __ ]
you know showbiz rule number one leave
him wanting more
don't keep singing to where they're like
alright although she wasn't the worst at
that like some of those [ __ ] divas
where they just go out there those whale
and horse where they just [ __ ] hit
every goddamn note at least they stopped
doing that stupid point thing where they
were pointing where them going down and
I'm going up yeah we can hear you we
know what you're doing do you do that
when you ride a roller coaster [ __ ]
point at everything you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Christina Aguilera is one of the worst
just like you know she never sang a song
she sang a song like she was a
auditioning for a band just sing the
[ __ ] song alright and get the goddamn
mud off you ass cheeks that's not sexy
you want to get dirty now I want you to
take a [ __ ] shower don't you go up
there wash off that clam and sing and
sing the goddamn song the way it's
supposed to go alright and Chris Brown
made me feel old
I was just sitting there like you know
that isn't music you call that dancing
is that really dancing is that what he
was doing
you know he looked like someone who like
who got healed you know was like a
paraplegic and somebody just touched his
forehead and now he was trying out his
legs for the first time in like 20 years
you know that awful [ __ ] auto-tune
[ __ ] where you're just so obviously you
know lip-syncing and I was ruined for
that guy I was excited he wanted Grammy
you know what's the last time somebody
slapped his [ __ ] out of a woman
everybody knew about it and within 3-4
years you won the little shiny thing
that doesn't happen often I'm trying to
think who was the last guy I don't know
and that was that was kind of a first
but I I don't know I didn't I didn't
like his I didn't like that music and I
didn't appreciate that dancing and I was
I was annoying the [ __ ] out of Nia as I
was watching it you know just being the
crabby old man pull up your pants did I
watch any further after that I think
that was it I think I could only watch
so much of a an award show I thought the
Civil War the civil wars or whatever
when they came out I thought that they
were gonna bomb and they [ __ ] killed
it you know so I'd like to download some
of the music I listened to some of it
like you know a little one-minute clip
but it sounded like all that real folk
kind of [ __ ] that I don't like but the
song that they sang was badass and I
thought the guy in the guitar was
killing it I don't know what you guys
think about the beach boy Mel with
melody I thought that melody whatever
the [ __ ] you call it medley I thought
they did a great job
somebody was trashing that guy in maroon
5 saying that what he did was the [ __ ]
did they say they said it was awkward at
best and what do they say cringe-worthy
at worse there's nothing cringe-worthy
about it they were doing a tribute to
the [ __ ] Beach Boys
what about when that guy came out the
one guy in the Beach Boys who has the
I'm bald now baseball hat on and he just
kept pointing to people in the crowd
I found him to be a little weird and uh
I don't know I think Brian Wilson I've
always said I know I've said this before
in the podcast I think he went crazy
just listening to his own music that
[ __ ] would just you know it's like these
amazing harmonies yet you feel yourself
going insane when you listen to him I
mean it's you know you feel like you
feel like you're on this never-ending
bus ride to camp when you're 14 and you
need don't want to go yet you're in your
40s listening to it I've never
understood I never got the Beach Boys I
don't get it all right they got a couple
of songs that it's just like if you
listen to it it's this really happy
poppy [ __ ] and then it's just really
dark [ __ ] lyrics underneath it and
you combine the two of them and I'm
telling you gonna go out of your [ __ ]
mind you know you know something
watching the Beach Boys really just
makes me realize that I have to have
some sort of I need to retire date you
know I know that's a [ __ ] mean thing
to say but there's just something now
maybe that's me being shallow as a
person like the same reason why I never
go to high school reunions you know I
should have gone when I was younger
that's when I should have gone but I'm
too old now I didn't go when I was
younger cuz I was a [ __ ] loser you
know people were married they had kids
what do you do I tell jokes I sleep on a
futon how many how many points is that
worth you're a comedian where do you do
it strip malls strip balls across the
country yeah yeah 3333 I'm actually
older than you yes I stayed back in the
first grade right out of the chute just
didn't get it now I'm too old I'm afraid
to go to a high school reunion cuz I
don't want to go there and meet people
who are divorced and they have problems
with a gallbladder I want to remember
all my classmates
the way I remembered him young with
their whole life ahead of them okay I
don't want to go there and talk to
somebody who used to make me laugh my
ass off and now they're [ __ ] sad
because they have child support payments
I don't want I don't want to see that I
want everybody to succeed I want that I
want to remember them the way you know I
saw actually when I when I do shows I
people come out to my shows that I went
to high school with and I get to meet
him like that it's been [ __ ] great
you know I ran into a really good friend
of mine when I was in Houston I haven't
seen this dude since [ __ ] eighth
grade
this kid was so [ __ ] funny the eighth
grade went by in like a week and a half
it felt like and I ran into him was
great he was doing great he married the
right person he was happy he's [ __ ]
hell and we just sat that telling
stories laughing going keep leave
[ __ ] 30 years has gone by since
eighth grade and blah blah blah like
that's the type of [ __ ]
so anyways getting back to that other
[ __ ] like you know the day I'm on stage
wearing my I'm going bald [ __ ]
baseball hat and I'm pointing to people
after my jokes and they're doing a
tribute to my jokes somebody please
shoot a [ __ ] dart into my neck and
just go bill just you know you got to do
something else at this point why don't
you teach a comedy class why don't you
do that I'm really set myself up for
failure here because I don't think I
ever can retire from this [ __ ] I like I
like it too much you know I don't know
you got to be excited though if you're
in Van Halen and you saw the Beach Boys
you know you got to be excited like you
just when you get to a certain age you
got to be a good there's somebody still
20 years older than me you know like if
I was in Van Halen I would show that
clip of the Beach Boys before I came out
just to you know spot yourself another
ten years of youth that's what I'm
saying although I've heard that new
album is [ __ ] I almost said terrific
for the first time I heard it's terrific
if you heard that new Van Halen Jesus
it's terrific
so anyways people Believe It or Not
ProFlowers is
still advertising in my podcast thanks
for keeping your [ __ ] mouth shut um
it is one day it is one day before uh
the hell's the goddamn copy
um it is one day before our Valentine's
Day everybody Valentine's Day is
tomorrow
so if you've not scheduled flowers to be
delivered then ProFlowers is gonna save
your ass and they really are at this
point you know are you like me did you
not get a card until it looked like you
know you know like when you wait too
long to get a card and you show up at
CVS and it looks like there was a ticker
tape parade they're like seven weeks ago
and nobody ever swept up you know and
you're like oh god what is left hey
there sugar tits I kind of love you you
know like I like those cards are left
hey you know I'm not really feeling this
but uh you are a hell of a bang happy
Valentine's Day
those are like the two cards that are
left you know or they just have one
that's just so [ __ ] over the top you
know it just you're the light in my eye
every time I inhale I smell you your
aura oh really you know then they have
like some [ __ ] picture of two people
about ready to kiss like just
silhouettes and it just makes your gives
you that queasy feeling in your stomach
you know you know that feeling you had
when you were a little kid like the
first time you thought about [ __ ] one
of your teachers and then you walked
into school and you saw him you like
this the [ __ ] was I thinking you know
was two new [ __ ] make sense anyways
let's get on with the ProFlowers read
here Valentine's Days tomorrow if your
buddy if you still haven't scheduled
your flower its flowers to be delivered
then ProFlowers is going to save you
they got your back you can still order
and have flowers delivered tomorrow
February 14th all right she'll think you
ordered these far in advance it will be
our little secret
look I like how ProFlowers is acting
like your little dirtbag friend don't
worry do what I ain't saying anything
that doing you a solid here alright you
order ProFlowers now you got to do it
now people all right who's kidding who
all right it's the 13th okay you're out
of time so this is the deal you go to
proflowers.com
you click on the Mike in the top right
hand corner and enter the code B you are
are all capitals for for this amazing
last-minute deal you basically you're
gonna get one dozen long-stem roses plus
a free glass vase you get chocolates and
a teddy bear don't eat the chocolates
you get them from ProFlowers chip for
just $39.99 or you can upgrade if you
really like this lady you get two dozen
long-stem roses with an elegant cherry
red vase you hear what just happened the
other one was just a free glass vase
they probably got an empty beer bottle
or something they stick him it so i
would go with the i would upgrade for
the extra 10 bucks $9.99 you get
chocolates a spa kit and teddy bear
right spot kit ladies love to be
pampered i need a spa day you know what
my spa day would be lady for you to walk
out of the house for a good four hours
don't be mean I'm not being mean I'm
being honest
it hurts some time all right so there
you go people
come on profile I was as cool as hell
that they rolled with what I did last
week and you guys actually are ordered a
bunch of flowers off of that could you
such psychos alright so do me a solid do
them a solid do your relationship is
solid go to go to proflowers.com
alright click on the microphone the top
right hand corner type in bu our hour
and get the little flower bonanza thing
that you need you know that's a really
good thing to do actually to just get
that out of the way you know to just
take her anger down a little bit here
you go his flowers teddy bear and a
chocolate alright
can she really be yelling at you holding
those three little props that's when you
know you screw up you know when your
girlfriend's holding a teddy bear that
you just bought and she's still calling
you a piece of [ __ ] and telling you to
get a goddamn job that's when you know
your life is [ __ ] up okay so use this
ProFlowers [ __ ] as a barometer if you
can get her those three things
what is it about women and stuff and
getting [ __ ]
is it cuz they got to give it up in the
bedroom but then then you know to
balance it out they have to get some
sort of like tangible objects you know
from day one if I ever said this before
I know even when you have a one-night
stand they try to get a t-shirt out of
it
they just they [ __ ] love stuff you
know I I hate stuff what's the deal is
good I don't like it like we need we
need a J a dresser in the bedroom and I
have been putting it off I just don't
want to have another [ __ ] thing that
I'm gonna have to move someday okay
everything's fine we have closets it's
not like this close pouring out of it
and if there are get rid of some clothes
you hoarder your [ __ ] Durr you know he
is sitting there going look like a fine
I actually given well we'll get a you
know we'll get a dresser drawer she's
like look just why can't we get one for
you and one for me no no we can't what a
[ __ ] am I gonna do that
cuz then you're gonna fill it up or feel
like you need to fill it up I'm such a
douche I should you know I'm gonna do
I'm gonna get one is it chest of drawers
dresser drawer of [ __ ] whatever the
ottoman whatever the [ __ ] you call the
damn thing I'm gonna get one of those
and I'm just gonna give it to her
alright there you go put all your little
foofy things in there your little
dollhouse stuff I know you're into that
[ __ ] there you go alright bago I will
keep all my [ __ ] in my closet well I
don't want to feel like I'm taking no
just [ __ ] take the thing gosh you
think so mean I don't understand why
you're gonna be so mean I don't
understand why we got to go to Ikea
every three [ __ ] days I can explain
that fine fine I'm just trying to make
the house look nice
you know I had this [ __ ] hilarious
conversation with Paul virzi of the day
and you know I got tell this [ __ ] he
won't believe this [ __ ] right I just got
done with my my red redneck tour through
the south all right
started off in Charlotte North Carolina
[ __ ] place was packed on a Tuesday
night I'm definitely coming back then I
went over to Hoover Alabama rod bought
Talladega you get on that 20 you go west
from Atlanta you go by Talladega and I
had a great time there I actually took
some video of Talladega uh I finally
gave in and I got the iPhone does can
anybody tell me how you [ __ ] zoom in
on that thing because I was trying to
take footage of Talladega and all my
footage is is there's Talladega [ __ ] do
you zoom in on this thing that's all it
is I'm gonna try to get that [ __ ] to my
web guy and have that put up this week
and then I did Atlanta then I did
Atlanta and I actually hung out in this
bar with a couple of friends of mine had
a great time at a couple of years and
the dude who owned it was a dive bar he
was right around the corner from the
Buckhead Theatre I forget the name of
the place it's a little pool hall went
in there had a couple of drinks and the
guy who owned the place had the sickest
[ __ ] tattoo I I don't think I think
I've ever seen he had on his upper arm
all right well you got the classic mom
tattoo you know he had a [ __ ]
portrait of Bill Murray on his arm his
upper arm and I know what you're
thinking you thinking that is the
dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard in my life
I'm telling you dude it was a [ __ ]
work of art it was incredible how much
this thing look like Bill Murray
it was the antithesis of that that UFC
fighter who has that awful Johnny Cash
that looks like Johnny Cash on some sort
of medication for some thyroid disease
with the heads all bloated and stretched
out this was the exact opposite and I
guess he's gonna get hunter arrest
Thompson on his arm and I'm telling you
if it's all gonna be of the quality of
this I took a picture of it it's [ __ ]
unbelievable so here's the deal here's
the fight I end up getting into with Nia
right with [ __ ] you know I just did
the redneck tour I was in Charlotte I
was in Hoover and then I was in Atlanta
all right started medium got in real
deep and then I came out of little
mainstream in [ __ ] Atlanta right and
I get off the plane and one of the one
of the first things out of her miles by
the way my I miss my flight
first flight I've missed since the late
90s I overslept and I couldn't get on
another flight to like you know my
flight was 18 8:15 in the morning I
couldn't get on until the 9:45 at night
and I actually got to the airport like
at 2:00 o'clock cuz like what am I gonna
do just keep driving around Atlanta we
drop off the rent-a-car soon enough to
pay for another day and then I spent
seven hours in the [ __ ] Airport I had
two meals at an airport like I started
off I showed up they had this soul food
thing right and I'm not a big soul food
fan I like the mac and cheese collard
greens are the saltiest most disgusting
things I've ever tasted in my life and I
got to tell you something
african-americans for all the [ __ ] talk
you talk about barbeque and you tell me
a good place to get some because the
[ __ ] that granted I'm at an airport but
I'm not seeing it it tastes like
everybody else's barbecue
it tastes like you've finished it 20
minutes ago it's a poor cut of meat you
know that's what barbecue is it's a poor
cut of meat that you have to slather all
this other flavor onto to disguise the
fact that I'm eating a cow ankle all
right I don't give a [ __ ] but I do like
mac and cheese so I got a plate of mac
and cheese that's the first thing I had
and what the [ __ ] else did I have one
point I had a hotdog
and a cookie that wasn't even good it
was the size of my [ __ ] head and it
wasn't even good is there anything worse
than that when you [ __ ] get a cookie
right just to say that you sound like a
[ __ ] douche
can I get a cookie right and you bite
into it and it's one of those cookies
that isn't good you know you kind of
poked at it through the package you're
like oh it's still soft oh good
they put that chemical in there that
prevented it from getting hard when it
hits you know the oxygen like there's
not oxygen in the stove you know what I
mean and then you go to bite into it and
it tastes like [ __ ] but do you ever
throw it out now you can't cuz you got
that little bit of sugar in you you're
already hitting the smack and you
[ __ ] eat you're just sitting there
eating an hour of sit-ups for no [ __ ]
reason you're not even enjoying it so I
did that for like seven hours then I
finally get on the [ __ ] plane and oh
you won't believe the [ __ ] I get on the
goddamn planes one of the funny sinks I
get on the plane and I'm looking at all
the people sitting in first class and
some woman got on and she had a toddler
with her sitting in first class and the
kid was already acting up and I saw one
of those selfish I'm never getting
married not having kids ever people I
caught him right in the moment that he
was discovering that despite the fact he
was in first class he was still going to
have a miserable experience and if you
saw the look of you got to be [ __ ]
me that look on his face I bursted out
laughing and he caught me looking right
at him and he knew that I knew why he
had that disgusted look on his face but
anyways I'm I'm telling this story like
a [ __ ] woman here where I keep doing
these offshoot stories so and this is
why we had the big fight alright I just
came from Charlotte Hoover Alabama in
Atlanta Georgia North Carolina Alabama
Georgia get off the plane one after
being delayed for 12 hours one of the
first things that comes out of her mouth
is she's like you know my mom was saying
that we should just take a short
vacation go to like New Orleans or
Memphis you know and I was like I don't
want to do that and then immediately I
just saw her energy change
there's just something about the side of
her face when she's [ __ ] mad at me and
I was sitting there going like you know
you knows there's something wrong or
whatever and she's like no I mean you
just keep going
but bla bla bla bla bla bla and they go
start doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
I'm in my head like you know what [ __ ]
you I kept telling she was mad and she
wouldn't [ __ ] own up to it then we
get home alright I bought the wrong
lightbulbs for the kitchen a few weeks
ago we have these awful [ __ ]
fluorescent light bulbs you walk in the
kitchen you feel like you're standing in
a fish tank that's been emptied alright
did she go out and buy the light bulbs
[ __ ] no that's too difficult I didn't
get around to it you know I can tell
she's pissed so she finally owns up to
the fact that she's like you know you
didn't have to bite my head off when I
brought up going to Memphis or [ __ ]
New Orleans and I was like I didn't bite
your head off I didn't I just said I
didn't want to go she goes I didn't ask
you to go I just said my mom said we
should go well that's saying you want to
go you know how about a little empathy I
just came from Charlotte Alabama and
[ __ ] Atlanta Georgia do I want to go
to Memphis no do you [ __ ] come up to
somebody after they just had a
Thanksgiving dinner and they're all
stuffed and go eh would you like a
turkey sandwich no we got into this huge
[ __ ] battle and then I got me and she
[ __ ] left to go do God knows what to
go hang out with their friends right
after giving me a speech about how we
haven't seen enough of each other she
again the ghost takes off to go hang out
with the [ __ ] friends right classic
female [ __ ]
so I call up furs and we just start
venting and I'm telling you dude like
there's that that thing nothing yet
another thing you have to avoid in a
[ __ ] relationship is like you ever
just feel like you're like you stopped
being the boyfriend of the husband and
you're just sort of the you like this
errand boy like every [ __ ] time you
go to walk out the door they
just add [ __ ] for you to go to hey where
you going I'm gonna go do this fun [ __ ]
oh can you go by the post office can you
pick up the dry cleaning
can you go restore this lamp
you know the dumbest thing you can
[ __ ] do is call your woman as you're
driving home don't ever do that to
yourself and when they call don't pick
up then you walk in I called you like
six times how come you didn't pick up I
was gonna ask you to sweep the sidewalk
and repaint the [ __ ] gate before you
came in no we had we had this big
[ __ ] battle I was like you talked to
me like I work for you I don't [ __ ]
work for you okay
no I'm not gonna go pick up light bulbs
you can't [ __ ] unscrew and screw in a
light bulb I just I forgot to do you
didn't forget to do it it's a pain in
the ass he didn't do it and now you
having me do it why do I have to do all
the pain in the ass [ __ ] there's a great
[ __ ] conversation for the day before
Valentine's Day
by the way I'm back on I'm on board for
that steak and a [ __ ] day alright but
it has to be done right okay which gets
me to the overrated underrated of this
week somebody said overrated steak and a
[ __ ] day men's Valentine's Day
because most chicks don't know how to
cook a steak and half of them don't
swallow Jesus all right I can help you
with the first half of that equation if
you have any sort of cooking talent
whatsoever ladies just go on YouTube and
you can find these YouTube videos that
will show you how to cook a steak
perfectly I thought I knew how to cook a
steak
I didn't there's all kinds of [ __ ] I
didn't know all right you just [ __ ]
pull you get the grill nice and hot you
sear it right on one side move it just a
little bit so you get the diamonds you
put it over the other side the same
[ __ ] thing and then you take it off
and you let it rest you don't cut right
into the [ __ ] you let it rest
and let all the juices go back all the
way through
it's [ __ ] one of the most the easiest
thing you get him [ __ ] do is cook a
steak it's not that hard okay so for
staking a [ __ ] day which I don't even
know what the date is
I need the date people tell me what it
is cuz I'm gonna be hyping that on this
podcast is you got to make sure it goes
down right okay
she's got to cook that steak right okay
with a couple little fixings on the side
if your favorite goddamn beer or
whatever and then afterwards she gives
you a nice [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you
know what that's it it's [ __ ] over
okay it's not like you start to blow me
and then we have sex and then you get to
have an orgasm - all right this is all
right your man's day for once don't let
him get anything okay for once you get
the t-shirt for once they pick up the
lightbulbs for once you sit there and
you get [ __ ] pampered you don't have
to do [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is she gonna do
for Valentine's Day huh get yourself all
dolled up and just sit there accepting
the food in the gifts to celebrate your
relationship if it's truly your
Valentine's Day you should be treated
the same you just [ __ ] lie there like
they do in the rack god I'm really being
an [ __ ] right now um what's that
would you like to hear another
commercial why here you go here's some
more guy stuff that you guys that you
can appreciate do you play video games
sure of course you do what are you
[ __ ] 8 years old yet you're 40 that's
the way to live life
I'm the new new advertiser for this week
everybody is Gamefly and actually this
to think about me I absolutely I love
video games to the point I can't handle
them okay because I lose I lose my like
video games are so good at this point
they're almost better than real life
like I told you I tapped at last I
tapped out Grand Theft Auto 3 that was
like eight years ago so I can only
imagine what what video games look like
now I should just come home you know
learned all the cheats on on grand theft
auto and I would get all the weapons and
I would just go onto the top of a roof
and I would just start killing people I
loved it I absolutely loved it just
blowing their [ __ ] brains out was
something that I totally loved so as I
said if you're a gamer you got you got
to go to Gamefly like if I was playing
video games this is this is the place
where I would go because basically you
go go check out their website on your
own it's pretty simple oh this is this
is actually this is something for me
this was actually actually a note for me
check out their website on your own but
it's pretty simple
see these advertisers already know I'm
stupid and you're driving people to the
below link so you can get credit for the
sales okay there you go I just read from
the playbook so here we go people
I'm gonna drive you to their website um
game flies basically it's the video game
rental system that delivers games to
your door and now directly to your PC
and isn't that what every gamer wants
don't you just want to sit there finish
it and then have another one delivered
to you you know like some fat guy
getting like endless box of doughnuts
let me try this one with jelly right
Gamefly has over 8,000 video console
games including new titles such as call
of duty modern warfare 3 Batman I don't
know what this is Arkham City did Batman
move I thought he was in Gotham City
look at this they're there they're just
so far ahead I don't know what's going
on and the elder scrolls what the hell
is that is that one of those games will
you build your own old folks home and
try to keep as many old people alive as
possible not Jesus Christ I really
should have gone to that website game
fly delivers right to your home there no
late fees or shipping fees and the costs
saving is amazing as a one-month
subscription as a fraction of the cost
of a newly released game in the stores
this is basically it so if you play
video games why when you go to game fly
8,000 videos they deliver them to your
door or straight to your PC and you with
all of that access that's cheaper than
buying one video game
that's it game set match listeners of
the Monday morning podcast will get a 15
day free trial of game day by going to
game WW gamefly.com slash burr you get
15 days for 8,000 videos use your sick
time use your vacation time just play
video games for 15 days for free you
don't have to buy anything WWE and fly
calm / / it's great for parents with
kids that play games hey parents you
have kids that you're sick of watching
stick them on in front of 8000 video
games they'll sit there like zombies
it's great for the guy that likes to try
out a bunch of different games but
doesn't want to pay or even that guy who
just has to play the hottest games out
there game fly is your spot goto
gamefly.com slash BIR for your 15-day
free trial come on people huh you got to
admit it as much as this advertising on
this podcast I'm hooking you up hooking
up with video games I'm hooking you up
with flowers you know
you think I haven't turned down some
awesome advertisers we had some people
coming on here wanted to advertise
fantasy football and I told him to go
[ __ ] themselves because I hate that [ __ ]
and I've been making fun of it for the
last 4 years
he's on my fantasy team if I could have
all my dreams come true daunte culpepper
would let me sit on his lap he's on my
fantasy team all right
let's get on with the podcast this is
the Monday morning podcast everybody and
I do one of these every goddamn week if
you knew I know we got some new
listeners out there and I do it every
Monday why to [ __ ] out what I'm doing
in my my little career here and also to
give you a little bit of a laugh I know
what you're saying well bill by the time
I listen to this it wasn't Monday
morning anymore really
well it's before 9:00 a.m. my time all
right
Jesus Christ when your favorite artist
writes some [ __ ] album called
September wins and it comes out in
January to you Susan took parent Birds
[ __ ] January it's not about you it's
about me all right hey I got an email
from Argentina
you guys have the internet down there I
didn't know that that's [ __ ] awesome
I'm breaking your balls
isn't that where ac/dc shot their latest
concert video and the fans were so
insane that it made me feel embarrassed
for the level of participation that I
had at the LA forum I'm gonna go out I
think ac/dc is bored when they tore the
states they have to be if they get that
kind of love in Argentina why the hell
would they want to go to our it's gotta
be like going to the airport for them
from Argentina hey Bill love your
podcasts I am I am growing listening to
your comedy [ __ ] I hope one day
a young fells the same for me JJ what
this is definitely a sacred language you
know I noticed Latino people when they
write haha it's je je which I guess that
makes I guess that's hehe cuz Jorge and
hey sue
start with the J that's hehe you know I
just figured that out
I finally had to talk it up did I figure
it out for my Latino listeners oh I am
beginning in stand-up comedy here in
Buenos Aires Argentina I feel I am a
funny person and I am trying to find
myself on stage me problem is that I
give a [ __ ] about what people might say
yeah well that's everybody's problem
when we start out this is a natural
progression here I'm trying to - don't
give a [ __ ] because I know it's not it's
not worth it
people suck but for one [ __ ] reason I
don't know I sometimes get nervous in
front of their judgemental faces bye
bill alright let's give it up for this
guy for being able to convey his
thoughts in a second language because I
could never do that I would be like
hello the girl drinks milk yellow a Dios
that's all I could say hola el Nene
Abimelech a I'm a real adios [ __ ] I wish
I could stick with that [ __ ] um anyways
alright what are we saying him
[Music]
the [ __ ] am I talking about what did he
ask me I just totally lost it I just
made me think about how I should start I
[ __ ] I'm never gonna be able to do it
I gotta start cheating on Nia with some
[ __ ] Mexican girl who only speaks
Mexican and I know I just said Mexican
speaks Mexican I know it doesn't make
sense but I don't know what to say what
you guys speak because if you say you
speak Spanish we don't speak Spanish
people from Spain speak Spanish well
what the [ __ ] do you speak anyway so
let's plow ahead here yes what the thing
you're going through sir is what every
stand-up comedian goes through and it's
great that you're this new to stand up
and you're actually asking these
questions not giving a [ __ ] on stage is
it's baby steps alright if everything
every time you go on stage you have a
goal when you're starting out I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna try this new bit doing
you know walking around with the mic
instead having the mic and the mic stand
makes me uncomfortable having the mic in
the mic stand I don't know what to do
with my hands at that point I'm gonna
face that fear and you just you know
just make little rules like that little
goals and then it becomes second nature
we don't even have to make rules or
goals goals is the word not rules and
you you will gradually progress and
always be trying new material and always
just keep pushing yourself and you all
that [ __ ] will fall into place you
should give a [ __ ] you knew to stand up
you don't quite know what you're doing
yet you got a ton to learn and you
realize that which is good that's a very
humble way to be there's nothing worse
than the [ __ ] supremely confident
open mic er you know they blow everybody
else away onstage but they peek early
because they just feel like they're the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and ah that's not true is it
gives a [ __ ] look you like me alright
you're a little timid you just keep just
keep working on it you'll you'll come
out of it and one day you'll be like me
standing on stage telling every to go
[ __ ] themselves even if they don't
deserve it
follow-up from October where do eggs
come from
where digs come out of oh yeah I asked
that I asked does it come out of their
ass do they have a little chicken [ __ ]
a little chicken vagina Billy Boy just
listen to the podcast from October and
you sort of asked where eggs come out of
a chicken he says I don't [ __ ] chickens
but well okay yeah I do know where they
come out of I know for a fact that the
egg comes out of the hole that poop also
comes out of it's called the vent BAM
educated you're welcome
that's disgusting well no wonder that
egg has a shell on it huh that's okay I
can still eat eggs and not worthy that
I'm eating eggs [ __ ] right cuz it's in
that little la that little more capsule
it's called the vent why doesn't a
[ __ ] uh a chicken have a [ __ ] is
that cuz it's so small is that what it
is is it like you know when you get a
car and there's you know you get the
compact so there's not enough room for
the radio so they turn it sideways like
in the Chevy citation is that what it is
so they had to combine the [ __ ] and
the the birth canal L at the same time
so every chicken takes it in the ass is
that what you're telling me where does
the rooster jizz know where to go I
didn't get pregnant again it went up the
[ __ ] rather than up the vent does a
rooster have to bang a chicken at a
certain angle to make sure it goes up
the vent that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense
is there a farmer out there that could
show me a semi a diagram it's got a it's
got a split at some point doesn't it
they can't be some egg growing in your
ass and you're also trying to take a
chicken dump you'd be constantly
constipated you know and when chickens
lay eggs there's nothing there's a bunch
of [ __ ] all over see sir this is what
this is the great thing about life is
you ask you answer a question and it
just introduces all the
others now I realize you know it's like
that little thing like with each book I
read I realized there's so much less
that I know see that so now I have I
have a hundred more questions and you
know what you decided to reopen this
Pandora's box now I need some follow-up
I got any farmers out there huh anybody
else can tell me it's got a split off
like one of those tea splits like when
you you know you and a friend listen to
the same iPod eggs and one [ __ ] in the
other that's like a game show it's time
to play put your hand I'll put your face
under the chicken vent what do you think
it's gonna be roll the dice this is
gonna be an egg or is it gonna be some
chicken [ __ ]
um that's disgusting bill well go [ __ ]
yourself I had to work with what I had
there all right advice hey Bill huge fan
I figured if there's anyone I should ask
for advice it's definitely should be
possibly the possibly insane guy that
rants into his weekly podcasts I'm not
insane I'm a little nuts
neiha keeps me sane I pay all my bills I
got a Prius you know go [ __ ] yourself
um so here's a story when I was in high
school I met a girl online do you guys
think I'm only qualified to answer [ __ ]
about relationships why don't you say
hey Bill I'm thinking about buying this
or buying that what do you think I
should do for the love of god I can't
answer any more of these [ __ ] questions
I think I've given I'm out of advice but
I'm a trooper I'm gonna continue here
when I was in high school and I met a
girl on I met a girl online whoo yes
this sounds weird but I was a senior her
a junior and the fact that we came
across each other was absolutely random
were you watching chick invent videos I
didn't know you liked those two anyways
we exchanged a few messages then text
messages then phone calls that's right
dude you're drawing her into your world
that's how you do it
and two weeks later I was in my car
driving the 1,000 miles to see her wait
a minute
wait a minute wait a minute we exchanged
a few messages then text messages then
phone call alright will you at least
sexting you at least doing that ensuring
the fact that you can never run for
president again without having those
those embarrassing texts show up from
that mother computer and somewhere in
Texas
[Music]
you've drove in a car a thousand miles
all right let's do the math here let's
say you can go 70 miles an hour that's
10 11 12 13 13 to 14 hours and that's if
you actually stop if you stop and get
something to eat on a 15 hour [ __ ]
drive I've done a 16 hour drive one time
I drove from LA to just beyond Denver
one day with the TV in the passenger
seat it's a long story
I had girlfriends before we're back to
the letter here my girlfriends before
but something about her was different I
spent the weekend in her city spent as
much time with her as possible and two
days later I had to say goodbye and
drive back home dude how much did that
cost and gas just get a Southwest flight
I told her I promised to come back and I
did I drove back two weeks later this
should be like a car commercial
then another few weeks later and again
and again over the next two years or so
I drove to see her probably 20 to 30
times this girl was incredible and all I
wanted was to be around her well why
didn't you just move there after two
years in 9,000 oil chains later later
after two years together I was sick of
having to say goodbye so I packed up and
moved to her city let me guess and then
it all falls apart because this was all
based on the romanticism of that you
couldn't be next to each other and now
you're gonna be next to each other and
this she snores or this is gonna be
something common about her and you're
gonna get sick of her that's my
prediction
anyways I enrolled in school got a job
and was able to see her every day I
think it's safe to say that not many
people would do this at the age of 19 or
at least go through it but I did
was certain I was going to marry this
girl after two years together I still
wanted nobody but her all right so so
far dude you've done nothing wrong
um even if she [ __ ] you over in this
she still did nothing wrong dude you
want to have to love there's nothing
wrong with that that's what you should
be doing after living there for about 10
months finances started catching up I
was unable to find a roommate bills were
getting higher and my job was
entry-level paying $8 an hour on top of
that I had school full-time as well I
had no choice but to move back home and
save money this was devastating I had
been back home for about five months I
haven't seen her since I moved I'm
getting ready to move back in a few
weeks but here's where things get
complicated she lives on campus at her
college a month ago she confessed that
she had sex we had been together but
frustrated because of the distance and
on a break we considered ourselves to
still still in a relationship talked
every day but we're just taking things
slow she confessed to having sex with
three different guys over the last month
she hid it from me yeah I know oh geez
it gets more complicated dude my [ __ ]
heart's getting ripped out here I
thought for once this was gonna work out
I thought for once the thing was gonna
be I gotta ask you when I get the tuxedo
for my wedding do I go tails no tails
I'm about 5 foot 11 that's the middle
ground I don't look like a penguin but I
think I'm tall enough
um it gets more complicated there was
always one issue with our relationship
she was a virgin when we met I was not
this bothered her and was a frequent
issue for the entire relationship and I
can understand why she tells me now that
even after what's happened she doesn't
know if she can she can be with me
because she can't get over the fact that
I had sex before meeting her I see this
as hypocritical considering she
basically cheated on me with three guys
I told her that I'm willing to forgive
and I would actually like to seek a
counselor together anything that can
help because this is how important she
is to me I would like your advice on
what I what you think I should do I know
the story is complicated but I still
feel that I should be with her and
forgive her I know I sound like a
dumbass cute
you're not a dumbass kid u-19 you're
supposed to be dumbass um alright
this girl is [ __ ] this girl's playing
you like a goddamn Stradivarius here
okay and she's not really you're both
young okay she doesn't want to be that
girl who married the first guy she met
she needs to play the field that's where
she is in her life right now she's not
gonna be happy with you because she
needs to go out and date a couple of
[ __ ] to realize you know it's like
if nothing bad ever happens to you in
your life you don't know what a good day
is you know you can't appreciate it
it's like those [ __ ] punk-ass kids
who have rich parents and they have
courtside seats you ever see him two
sitting there [ __ ] there they're on
their little cell phones texting away
they're bored you know if I was eight
years old and I got to sit courtside at
a Celtics game my eyes would have fell
out of my head and rolled across the
[ __ ] floor I I wouldn't be able to
conceive of it cuz we were always
sitting up in the red right so this is
the same thing with her she doesn't
realize what a great guy she is so let
her go dude go ahead go bang those other
[ __ ] guys and dude you're only 19
why don't you know that's you ever see
the [ __ ] Bronx Tale you got three
great women in your life that was your
first one you got another two in the
[ __ ] shoot alright and maybe they
won't live a thousand miles away okay
and need to go jump on 12 other dicks to
understand what a great guy you are
alright I just read thanks bill go easy
on me alright I am going easy on you I'm
giving you some [ __ ] tough love here
love here okay this at this ain't the
time dude you're gonna move all your
[ __ ] out there and they're still there
gonna be that itch that she hasn't
scratched yet she needs to [ __ ] it's
not even she's gonna go out and bang a
bunch of other guys she just she has to
figure herself up first who she is what
the [ __ ] she wants what she wants to
major and you're too young you're too
young
all right
dude all right you're a romantic you got
a big heart you drove [ __ ] 50,000
miles and the girl ended up breaking
your heart I mean it's it's inevitable
there's a thousand miles of distance and
you're young all right so what I was do
why don't you focus on yourself all
right
and like I said this is gonna suck and
you know what just you know what just
tell her look I think that you need some
time to live your life and when you're
ready to come back to me you call me put
the ball in her court all right let that
[ __ ] come to you all right you've been
coming to her to the tune of [ __ ]
30,000 40,000 [ __ ] miles I think
you've come her way enough all right I
don't see her [ __ ] moving down the
way you're at you keep going to where
she's at dude you're setting yourself up
to be a [ __ ] slave look it I set my
relationship up good and I still ended
up being [ __ ] errand boy this past
week and I had to put my foot down okay
you know much of a piece-of-shit knee
will be treating me if I drove a
thousand [ __ ] miles and forgive to
from banging three other guys don't set
yourself up with that all right
you deserve better all right you're a
good guy [ __ ] that [ __ ]
all right I think it's time that you
thought about yourself and your [ __ ]
vehicle let her come to you all right
this is what you do what you tell her
just say listen I understand it you
gotta live your life all right when you
done living your life and you want to
come see me you know where I live I
think it's about time you came and you
paid me a visit all right maybe that's a
little too harsh say something like that
but not with the [ __ ] tone that I
have all right all right here we go
number two bill I'd appreciate some
advice in something I've been with my
girls since I was 15 and now I'm 22 guys
I can't do these [ __ ] relationship
things anymore I'm sick of them this is
the last one I'm doing okay at least
let's [ __ ] try and switch him up here
bill I'm thinking about getting solar
panels what do you think I'm now 22 for
the past five years we've been
long-distance through University and now
our first jobs yet this relationships
over over the five years the odds thing
has happened which has made me worried
that I can't trust her not full-on
cheating but a couple of times it came
out that she was being dishonest
she once got drunk and played strip
poker with some of her girlfriends she
told me there were no guys around I
found out later from one of her friends
that there actually was that's it dude
that's it the main chute didn't come out
pull the [ __ ] ripcord you are going
terminal velocity - [ __ ] splat 'n
dick first and then your heart right
into the ground dude you don't need
advice okay you just need to be nudged
over dump this dumper it's over she's
not a [ __ ] if she did this when she was
35 she's a [ __ ] she's not a [ __ ] she's
doing what the [ __ ] you do when you're
that age okay that's what you're
supposed to be doing okay if we learn
anything this week people long-distance
relationships do not work they don't
work okay and sir you're gonna be honest
and tell me that you haven't [ __ ]
around you didn't get a little drunk and
accidentally uh you know whoops is that
your titty I'm sorry right you haven't
done any of that a little over a year
ago she was on her way she was away on
business and claims one of her workmates
tried to kiss her dude I don't need the
rest of it to read the rest of this and
I'm not torturing my fans by reading the
same [ __ ] thing
okay and he ends with really sorry for
the essay I appreciate any wisdom you
can impart you already heard it on the
first one dude it's over it's open you
know what - there's nothing that you did
the only silver lining of when you're
getting [ __ ] over like this is when
you break up with the person alright
just say listen I love you to death but
I can't trust you anymore alright and
when you can't trust somebody the
relationships over I can't trust you
okay I don't hate you I wish nothing but
the best for you and but you know this
isn't what I'm looking for in a
relationship okay
toodaloo and that's how you end it okay
and I guarantee you dude you guaranteed
she won't be able to handle the level of
maturity and you'll probably get at
least a [ __ ] and a half she'll get
halfway through the second one and be
like okay what are we doing I'm confused
I got to get out of here so just take
the first one okay is your your your
severance package that's your gold watch
out of this thing no more long-distance
relationships people all right and why
don't you guys give me a break
I can't talk about any more of this
[ __ ] relationship stuff I would still
like to give advice I I'm not qualified
to give advice I just do this because
it's [ __ ] funny and we're doing the
same subject over and over again hey
Bill I bought a Rubik's Cube in 1983 and
I still can't solve it you know
give me something some other springboard
to [ __ ] jump I want to dive into a
different comedic pool everybody you
like that that's from my syllabus of my
stand-up comedy class you think I'm not
gonna teach one someday you think I'm
not gonna retire from the road and get
myself a tweed sport coat with the elbow
patches and come walking in and be all
serious about comedy dance like [ __ ]
Michael Douglas in that [ __ ] show
with those [ __ ] with the glittery
pants I actually like that musical one
singular sensation you know I like
watching those [ __ ] do that Fosse
thing there's something about it that
you know that's the only musical my dick
has ever given a [ __ ] about and for
those of you out right out there writing
musicals okay you want to write a
[ __ ] musical that's gonna be a hit
where you can get all kinds of extra
money is you got to make it there's got
to be something in there that a
heterosexual guy is gonna like all right
if you can make me go there and I don't
give a [ __ ] that I'm watching a bunch of
people sing and dance and there's no
there's no I don't know what the [ __ ] do
I need there's no ball nobody trying to
stop somebody from scoring a goal none
of that [ __ ] you there's got to be I'm
not saying they got a [ __ ] it up but
you there's got to be there's got to be
something you know there's got to be
something that makes my dick go oh what
what is this you know if you just do
that every ten minutes
ooh I like you know I haven't been
paying attention I don't have no idea
what the plot is but I like what she's
doing you know I could direct one of
those I would say the same thing to
every dancer in it
I don't care if it's a rake stage you're
not gonna fall over okay just get your
[ __ ] balance down now you like that
rake stage I've been around it
alright overrated underrated for this
week
rake stage means they tilt it down they
cheat it down towards the audience so
they can actually swim front row can see
it a little bit better and you know I
used to date a dancer
alright overrated or underrated green
tea I'm not a doctor and I certainly
don't know how much about healing I
don't know much about healing of any
type of viruses naturally but after
drinking three cups of green tea a day
over the past five days my head coal and
heavy cough have pretty much dissipated
dude if you didn't do [ __ ] after five
days the common colds gonna go away but
if you think this is your little voodoo
cup have at it he said I usually hello
typical me I don't read anything I
usually have slow recoveries when I get
sick - usually a two to three week
process every time I catch a cold this
stuff almost got rid of it the last of
it in three days really good stuff kind
of therapeutic - well if it works for
you keep doing it but I would probably
try to eat some fruits and vegetables
get eight hours sleep you know and
listen to me I'm not a doctor
overrated shampoo and conditioner I just
watched my hair with a Costco brand body
wash and not only is it softer than it's
been in a while it also smells good
that's tremendous
do you know what something I actually
love Costco I nedd never been there
before in my life I I loved it I loved
the Armageddon sized did I talk about
this already you know a good friend of
mine told me a while ago
Aisha Tyler look at me name-dropping a
little fancy Hollywood person she does
the girl on guy podcasts once again
right there you see the name of that all
of you out there were like I don't need
to listen to another podcast what did
she do she makes you dick just a little
bit interested girl on guy podcast oh
you did
like what's that I think I will have a
listen if you could just take that
formula and put it into a [ __ ]
Hollywood Hollywood a Broadway musical
more straight guys would go if every
once in a while you just threw that in
there that maybe you were gonna see a
live sex act
that's an idiot anyway she told me that
that's the place to buy boost that's the
place where you buy you booze all right
and I'm gonna tell you goddamn it she
was [ __ ] right I bought a redneck jug
of [ __ ] Jack Daniels for like 30
bucks you know you just you just looking
at it like if I drank all of that in a
bar that would cost me probably about 2
grand do you like how I'm talking about
Costco like it's this brand-new store
that only exists a mile from my house
yeah bill what are you gonna tell us
that next the wonders of shopping at
Walmart now go [ __ ] yourselves all right
that's the podcast for this week I have
things to do people I don't have time to
sit here my Jam jams for the rest of the
day and my [ __ ] Red Sox bathrobe did
I get to everything
Oh stamps calm stamps calm the last one
everybody stamps calm I've been using
I've been using this exclusively I've
been to the post office in three weeks
and I can tell you I don't miss him you
know they like that girlfriend that I'm
finally over there in there in my
rearview mirror anytime I need stamps I
print them out right from my computer
anytime I got to send out a package they
set me up with this little scale I weigh
the whole thing I'm telling you I'm
gonna buy it one of those little visors
I got my own little post office right
here at home in my pajamas once you get
the supplies you're all set so basically
this is how it goes
stamps calm you can buy and print
official US postage with your own come
with your own computer and printer you
can print stamps and shipping labels for
any letter or package the instant you
need it yeah because they give you the
scale they give you the paper to print
them out on and then you just stick it
out by your mailbox and they pick it up
you don't have to go to the post office
ever again all right you know and I'm
not gonna I'm not trying to act like a
fancy guy but I'm a busy dude and one of
the things I
is having to go to the bank or go to the
damn post office okay I can't wait till
they come out with Bank calm where I can
stick cash in cuz I'm not putting my
bank account number on the internet
that's why I draw the line but you know
the stamps I'm all over it
alright they got a special offer
everybody right now if you go to stamps
com use my last name burr B you are are
no risk trial plus a hundred and ten
dollar bonus offer includes a digital
scale and fifty-five dollars in free
postage you can either do that in stamps
or if you got somebody's birthday coming
up and you want to go mail him a [ __ ]
wigwam or something you can just slap it
right on there
alright I'm telling you don't wait go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Barbie you
are are at stamps calm enter B you are
are I really appreciate you guys you
guys have actually been doing this stuff
and I like the amazon.com thing has
really been blowing up if you're new to
my podcast if you go to the Billboard
comm click on the podcast page and you
click on the Amazon link you know if you
know just if you're gonna buy some on
amazon.com
they give me a kickback at ten percent
of that I send to the Wounded Warriors
Project and you know I gotta wait three
months to get the first check but when I
do I got a nice check going towards the
troops so it's been an all good thing so
I really appreciate you guys
participating in all this advertising
and not breaking my balls about it
because look the podcast is still free
right we get it built
shut your face hiking gigs for this week
this week I am gonna be in New Jersey as
I always am right after New York wins a
championship I'm always in New Jersey
Boston wins a championship for some
reason my next gig is in [ __ ] Utah I
don't know why it works out that way but
it always seems to so this is the deal
this week I am I am blonde storming
through New Jersey Long Island and up
into Connecticut I'm at the Bergen
actually I'm at the stress factory for
them hurricane make up date on the 15th
I think those shows are sold out check
with Vinny Brandt at the stress factory
and next I'm at the Bergen
pack Theatre in Englewood New Jersey
February 16th February 17th I'm at the
Fox Theater in Connecticut we added a
second show that is almost sold out on
the 18th I'm at the theater at Westbury
I guess the Westbury theater in Westbury
New York all of those shows if they're
not sold out or about ready to be sold
out so please for the love of God go to
billboard.com click on shows click on
the link get yourself some tickets I
need you guys to come out to these shows
because I'm getting ready to take my
next stand-up special so it really helps
me when you guys show up and please just
laugh at what you think's funny don't
laugh if you don't think it's funny just
that's all I ask you and we'll be all
good
and the following week 23rd 24th 25th my
triumphant return to the comi works in
denver why is it triumphant I don't know
I just felt like saying that that's it
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves oh I didn't even talk about
the fact that I am a bandwagon New York
Knicks fan I still can't root for them
to win a championship because they're a
New York team but that Jeremy Lin kid I
watched that Lakers Knicks game on the
airplane and I got to tell you dude
flying back from Atlanta that's the most
exciting NBA game I've seen in a long
time and when he took that charge at the
end of the game I almost stood up and
started cheering and it just has to do
with the fact that that kid was almost
out of basketball and also he's playing
that basketball that they played when I
was a kid you know oh you youngsters out
there you don't understand how much
Michael Jordan affected the game
actually in a bad way he was so good
that he actually [ __ ] the game up
because before then it really was a team
sport like in the 80s when I was growing
up and you were in you were playing
basketball you know what we used to
always do we used to always somebody
always pretended they would DJ and then
some and somebody was Larry Bird you
always try to do that backdoor pass that
was good for [ __ ] six points every
goddamn like once a game somehow bird
always got free in the baseline and DJ
will did like the no-look back to a
[ __ ] past that's what you wanted to
do you wanted to be you know Magic
Johnson given a no-look pass to your
buddy who's pretending to be worthy and
he puts the ball up like he's gonna
but then he's white so at the last
second he's got to lay it in and
everybody laughed everybody had that
playmaker point guard that got everybody
involved and that's what she wanted to
be and and Jordan was so good he defied
every [ __ ] rule right down to the
rules of gravity where he was just [ __ ]
my teammates um Lisa's my supporting
test I can win without a big man I don't
need to pass and and he could do it cuz
he was that good but then everybody saw
that and then they tried to do that and
who's kidding who you're not [ __ ]
Jordan you know and everybody tried to
be Jordan for like ten [ __ ] years and
that kid there on the Minnesota
Timberwolves if the NBA can come back to
that again I will start [ __ ] watching
because there's nothing better than
watching a point guard that gets
everybody involved and I love Kobe as
far as what the [ __ ] that guy does but
watching the Knicks go down the court
and then watching Kobe's go they go down
in a cluster there's Kobe by himself and
then everybody else is all together and
if Kobe gives up the ball the second he
does he's clapping and he wants the
[ __ ] thing back and I don't give a
[ __ ] if he's got three guys hanging on
him and he's ten feet behind the [ __ ]
arc and he's got two guys wide open now
because he's being triple team you got
an 80% chance that he's gonna [ __ ]
shoot the ball but the son of a [ __ ]
hits it so he can't be mad at it but
kids just see that [ __ ] and that's how
they try to play hoop and I'm telling
you watching this kid [ __ ] getting
everybody involved you had no idea what
he's gonna do he come in is he gonna
split the defenders he's gonna kick it
out to somebody for the open three he
goes in for the old-school reverse layup
was [ __ ] insane so uh I am AI AM a
bandwagon Knicks fan right now cuz I
watched that kid every night if that's
how he's gonna [ __ ] play but I will
root like hell that they don't win a
[ __ ] championship the amount of
poundings that I took this week doing
morning radio in New Jersey for all my
jersey gigs oh my god I took thrashing I
got pounded by some state I just got
pounded there's nothing I could say I
went down swinging but I got pounded
and it's [ __ ] hilarious last year
they were all Jets fans they all had on
their sanchez jerseys and this year
everybody's a giant fan it's
unbelievable
it's almost like they switch loyalty
bill you went so long without being a
[ __ ]
alright that's it god bless you go [ __ ]
yourself I'll talk to you later
you